shia labeouf is a talented actor but he
is also no stranger to trouble
and now two famous singers have come
forward with disturbing allegations
about their troubled relationships
with shia shia stepped out looking
sullen in new photos taken saturday a
day after ex-girlfriend
fk twigs filed a bombshell lawsuit
against him
she is accusing the actor of sexual
battery assault
and knowingly giving her an std
now twigs is getting support from fellow
musician sia
who took to instagram writing i too have
been hurt emotionally by shaya
a pathological liar who conned me into
an adulterous relationship
claiming to be single i believe he's
very sick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shia starred in sia's 2015 music video
for elastic heart
at the time he was dating ex mia got sia
did not elaborate on when their alleged
relationship occurred
cheyenne fk twigs born talia barnett
met on the set of their 2018 movie
honeyboy
she claims their tumultuous relationship
quickly turned into a
living nightmare and around valentine's
day 2019
shia forcibly slammed her against his
car
and strangled her when it comes to the
std
she alleges shaya covered a flare-up by
applying makeup
so what is shy saying about all of this
he told the new york times quote
many of these allegations are not true
but went on to add
i have no excuses for my alcoholism or
aggression
i have been abusive to myself and
everyone around me for years
i'm ashamed of that history and am sorry
to those i hurt
wonderful cheyenne's last on-screen
appearance was september's fast times at
ridgemont high
virtual table read for charity he played
stoner spicoli
just come on just don't just come on
the transformers an indiana jones star
is notorious for his many run-ins with
the law
throughout his career
here he is in 2017 being arrested for
public drunkenness
and disorderly conduct in georgia which
resulted in court-mandated rehab
three years earlier he was arrested for
drunken heckling at the broadway musical
cabaret
tell us what happened that same year he
walked a red carpet wearing a bag over
his head that read
i am not famous anymore he also staged a
bizarre performance art exhibit
titled i am sorry where he interacted
with fans one-on-one inside
he took off the bag and he took a
picture with me most recently
in september shia was charged with
misdemeanor battery
and petty theft for an incident in which
he took a man's hat
he is due in court on january 20th i
actually attended that art installation
and uh it was just a very bizarre
[Music]
situation